デカいね
うわぁぁぁ
おお、ああ、おぉぉ
ホラ
すげぇ
いい港ですよ
だから、見せないでよ
ハハハハ！
はい
フィッシャーズという
おもしろい、YouTubeのチャンネルがありまして
そこのボスなんですけど
ほら、フィッシャーズの面白さをちょっと売名しときなさい
だから、やりづれぇんだって。それ
何をしてるチャンネルですか？
えーと、基本はー
もう全部、ギャ…
僕の後輩が
今からたまたま、ぼくん家に来たいと言ってまして
はい
あー、任せてください
えっ？
（LINE着信音）
今？
もしもーし
今何してます？
早く来てほしいです。
会いたいです。
まあまあ面倒くさいって
ま、せっかく二人いるんで
ちょっと、また、ドッキリを仕掛けれないかと
いつも僕一人でやってるんで、
2人でしかできない新しいフォームのドッキリを
仕掛けてやろうかと思いまして
僕が前日椅子を買ったときに
めちゃくちゃデカい段ボールが届いたんですよ
あの段ボールに僕さっき入ってみたんですけど
全然僕で入れたんで
僕んちの地下は今段ボールだらけで
めっちゃ段ボールが散らかってるんすよ
なんで、ああいう段ボールがポッと置いてもほぼ気づかない
あ～、そうっすか
僕、こっそりその段ボールの中に隠れて
まさきは、シルクが家にいることを知ってるんすよ
うん、そうっすね、うん
だから、シルクが普通におめ？迎えすると
あぁ
お出迎えすると。
ふはっ、おめ迎え
ふぁっ、おめ
お出迎えすると
で、あ～っ！